well there is demand for uber and lyft
rides in southern nevada but just not
enough drivers on the road
while it frustrates locals and visitors
alike 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond showing us how
it is really helping bring business back
to a certain service
rideshare woes it took us like 20 25
minutes to wait for the uber we ordered
a lift
and we waited and waited and it was 30
minutes or so and it still didn't showed
up
some at the famous welcome to fabulous
las vegas sign noticed
problems when ordering a lift or uber a
trend
making julius caesar and others consider
another
option we thought about taxis a couple
times we had people suggest them to us
with locals and visitors having issues
with ride sharing services
some taxi cab companies are now seeing a
demand in business
we've been getting a lot of calls
through the right share not being there
for the public
mariano lucaso manages deluxe taxi cab
service
he notices drivers getting more rides
especially during march madness
business as a whole has been really good
this month tourists are coming back
locals are on the move but the industry
overall continues to struggle meeting
pre-pandemic numbers
data from the nevada taxi cab authority
shows monthly trips in february
down by 65 percent compared to february
of 2020.
definitely not back to last year's
numbers i mean
but we're definitely going in the right
direction locashow adds
taxi cab companies need drivers now the
man is going up and
the drivers are not there why haven't
your drivers come back
a lot of them just we couldn't find them
they just disappeared
and a lot of drivers are still scared
creating a job opportunity
for those seeking work kristin drummond
8 news now
now we reached out to uber and lyft
regarding the lack of drivers both
companies blame the state of emergency
in nevada pausing surge pricing at the
moment which normally
incentivizes drivers now you can read
both companies full statements
on our website over at 8newsnow.com